Possessing a fine mind for strategy, mechanically
inclined, with true and loyal friends, and
a fair amount of luck, the greatest zoo jailbreak
artist of all time, Ken Allen, was the El
Chapo of orangutans.
Born at the San Diego zoo in 1971, Ken’s
early life was marked by sadness when he had
to be removed from his mother’s care, as
zookeepers felt she was on the verge of smothering
him to death.
Named after two of his rescuers, Ken Willingham
and Ben Allen, after removal he became rather
comfortable with the humans who helped raise
him.
Perhaps zookeepers should have anticipated
Ken’s later escapes since, even as a young
adolescent, according to the San Diego Zoo,
he would regularly unscrew the bolts in his
cage at night, roam the nursery, and then
return and put his cage back together in the
morning.
Suspecting something was amiss, the zookeepers
ultimately caught him at this and his nightly
fun was ended.
As with human teenagers, when Ken was 14 he
decided to test his boundaries, and made his
first pen escape on June 13, 1985 by climbing
up and over the retaining wall of his enclosure.
Friendly and confident, Ken reportedly calmly
strolled along with patrons of the zoo observing
other animals before zookeepers learned of
his escape and were able to lead him back
to his cage, which he was seemingly perfectly
happy to re-enter.
Although zoo officials feared Ken’s escape
would create a PR disaster, as he was so mild-mannered
about the whole thing, the opposite happened
and Ken ultimately became a folk hero – to
the point that “Free Ken Allen” shirts
and bumper stickers began to appear, and there
was even a song, The Ballad of Ken Allen.
Not wanting a repeat performance, zoo officials
beefed up security in his pen, including installing
a large moat with a massive wall to keep the
250 pound orangutan in.
However, just a few weeks later, on July 29,
1985, Ken escaped again.
This time, however, he decided to use his
time a bit more productively and went to the
pen holding his archenemy, an orangutan named
Otis.
When zookeepers arrived, they found Ken pelting
Otis with rocks.
On August 13, 1985, Ken called upon his ingenuity
again, and found a branch of sufficient size
and strength to use as like a crowbar; enlisting
the help of one of his lady friends, an orangutan
named Vickie, Ken instructed her on how to
pry open an exit using the branch.
Successful, Vickie freed both of them, although
they were once again captured almost immediately.
After the third escape, Ken was moved for
a time while zoo officials spent thousands
of dollars investigating his enclosure, including
even hiring experienced rock climbers to find
every finger, toe and foothold in the enclosure.
Further attempts were made to improve the
design of his enclosure via attempting to
watch Ken probe his pen for potential escape
spots.
However, Ken soon seemed to figure out what
his captors were trying to do and simply ceased
such attempts when zookeepers were watching.
In response, said individuals had to resort
to dressing up as tourists to clandestinely
observe him.
Finally as a sort of general security improvement,
zookeepers ran an electric fence wire along
the top of the exterior wall of Ken’s enclosure
and turned it on.
This prevented at least one escape when Ken
managed to once again make it to the top of
said wall, but this time was zapped and retreated
back into his cage, seemingly defeated for
good.
Au contraire!
Ken had merely been biding his time, and two
years later he escaped when the moat’s pump
went offline, which dried it up sufficiently
for Ken to walk across and hoist himself up
and over once again.
This time, according to reports, Ken didn’t
return so quietly as in previous escapes.
When the fuzz came to take him back to his
home, he took off – giving the zookeepers
a bit of a fright as he was heading directly
toward the lion pens where they feared he
might climb inside.
That potential crisis was averted, however,
as the zookeepers were able to catch him before
he made it there.
Seeking to distract him from attempting to
escape again, and thinking maybe he was a
bit jealous of Otis who lived with three lady
orangutans, zookeepers put four females in
with Ken, “hoping to turn his wanderlust
into just lust.”
This completely backfired, however, as Ken
recruited his new friends to join in his escapades.
A few months later, two of his protégés,
Jane and Kumang, found and transformed a five-foot
squeegee left behind in the pen into a tool
to, once again, scale the wall.
Jane made it all the way to the flamingos
before having to be tranquilized, but Kumang
returned to the enclosure agreeably.
This was the last of Ken’s and his friends’
escapes.
In total, the zoo reportedly had to spend
approximately $45,000 to make Ken’s enclosure
escape proof over the course of his escapades.
Sadly, although orangutans in captivity can
live up to 60 years, Ken, only made it to
29.
In 2000, he was diagnosed with B-cell lymphoma.
While normally an attempt might have been
made to treat his cancer, particularly given
his young age, his case was deemed to be terminal,
so rather than put him through the difficult
treatment with almost no chance of it being
successful, on December 1, 2000, he was euthanized.